[somber music]
NEWSCASTER 1: The armed
revolutionary forces
of Colombia known as the
FARC is the most powerful
guerrilla group in the country.
They control the areas where
large amounts of the world's
cocaine is produced.
NEWSCASTER 2: They are
known as paramilitaries.
They celebrate a legend
of heroic defiance
against the kidnappers.
Their mission is to achieve
what the army cannot--
defeat the guerrillas.
[somber music]
NEWSCASTER 3: 12 died and
more than 200 passers-by
were injured in this
recent explosion.
Another outrage was to follow.
This time, there was no
mistaking the culprit's
identity.
That left their
signature at the scene.
NEWSCASTER 4: Pablo
Escobar couldn't
stay out of the public eye,
and that's what killed him.
He died in a hail of
bullets as he tried
to get away across a roof.